fans are already feeling the love
tonight or make that last night for
Disney's live-action Lion King it raked
in twenty three million dollars alone
but overseas are roaring 100 million
dollars and Counting insane and that is
just the start because beyonce is making
sure everyone is feeling the spirit of
the film including her daughter Blue Ivy
the skinny new singer that's the 7 year
old getting a solo on Beyonce's new
album
The Lion King the gift inspired by her
role as Nala went on sale today
spirits extended music video also
co-starring Blue Ivy already has 13
million YouTube views you don't know
what this will mean to everyone that all
makes it pretty surprising to hear that
beyonce actually had a case of nerves at
the lion Kings London premiere meeting
the Royals we're all kind of nervous
even Beyonce you know we were really
yeah because the Royal Billy Eichner
tells Jimmy Kimmel that he started
getting nervous days before they email
you a protocol Oh
of how you're supposed to greet Prince
Harry and Megan and they are very
intense about it what's the model
nothing what's the model with you
Billy plays Timon the wisecracking
meerkat he and his sidekick Seth Rogen
Pumbaa are being called the movies scene
stealers Oh everyone calm down we're
here it was amazing to to again see that
people seemed to be really enjoying it
and overall yeah okay kuna Matata might
be their signature song but the guys say
that audiences are hooked from the
opening number
[Music]
it's so good we have a version that's
gonna be released we've been working on
yeah yeah and it's in the Yiddish stop
to give a little boy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]